foreign see that it's true
all right let's see what you got
zucchini Target
a girl
oh we're killing it that's cute you go
up
good girl good and she's holding that
longer too that's really good
she's like oh nice here see if she'll
Target to you
can you do it I can Target
that was
that's so stinking cute I'm doing it
again okay Target
[Music]
good job I got so distracted
good work sister yeah man they're
seriously cool animals
she peed on you again
[Music]
you're in for it today Sean
look at that amazing hydration that she
has yes
look at her little face
we have two shingle back skinks one cold
Spike and one called Vegemite I call
Vegemite Big Daddy just because I really
enjoy giving animals little nicknames
which help me connect with them on a
more personal level they both came to us
from a different institution and it was
very apparent within the days that they
arrived that the big guy seemed pretty
good pretty normal and seemed ravenous
to food and spiked the little one was
fairly thin and one of the things that
the staff have noticed is that she
really doesn't take in a lot of food
compared to the big guy
I'm just worried she's going to continue
to not eat and potentially waste away
so we need to figure out if there's
something else going on with her
incredibly rare not a common species
that you see in zoos and Aquariums so
let's do the little one real quick and
then we'll do the big guy yes today
we're going to be doing the bearing
comparative study we really want to try
and compare how big the stomach is in
the so-called normal skin versus Spike
so I'm going to mix a bit of food just a
tiny bit to get the thickness and then
mix barium so it'll be a nice
consistency
barium is commonly used to highlight the
structures that are within the GI tract
on x-rays so it looks very very white on
an X-ray so it's really easy to see
where you put it and also how long it
takes to go out of the system super
adorable little girl she's adorable all
right little one Barium test we're
giving us an idea of how large the
stomach actually is to understand if
this is an animal that can consume the
right amount of food to gain weight
look at our cute little hand look okay
shingleback skinks are really really
cool they are called shingle back skins
because of the shingles on their back
they're a lizard species that kind of
look like the top of a roof with all of
the shingles overlapping there's very
few shingle back skinks in Susan
aquarium so there isn't a lot of data
out there on this species all right
Daniel
Vegemite Big Daddy
he's just super cute
oh man this is a very different animal
yeah very different it's like Jabba the
Hutt isn't he cute it's really cute and
then chuck her to that one chunky but
our big step is now is we just want to
know is her internal makeup the same as
Vegemite Vegemite we feel is fairly
healthy animal we know that he's packing
on weight we know that he's consuming
food but we want to be able to
understand is internally are they the
same that's better
our next step here is we'll do a couple
more x-rays we'll be able to see if
there's movement with the barium to get
a better understanding of how far this
barium is moving through the body and
not only show us where the stomach sits
in Spice body but also to what size
another reptile mystery closer to being
sold
306. good hey buddy you want to come
with me and Jan to take a look at Lulu
yeah it's import I can do that we'll
meet you down here at the barn I'll meet
you guys down here this thing virus was
supposed to go away in summer yeah your
kids going back to school is your wife's
School opening I don't know yeah Lulu
our giraffe is pregnant with her second
baby and due date is coming up she's
starting to get a little bit of milk in
her utter and having some other signs of
being close to giving birth so Kurt and
I are going to go out with Adam and just
have a look at her and see how close we
think she is she is getting close I was
off for like four days and I came back
and I can see a heck of the difference
the front teeth bagging up
oh she's big isn't she oh my see how
before our goals oh my goodness
girlfriend don't worry you guys just
stay there yeah I'll get the gate you
can get this gate for us yeah yeah no
problem we hate to get out
it's hot out there
the giraffe infant mortality rate really
is pretty high both in human care and in
the wild believe it or not so we are
still going to watch this baby so
carefully and watch her so carefully
just to make absolutely sure we're doing
everything in our power to have her be
successful how long's our other been big
a week or week and a half okay she's
still eating well and behaving normally
yeah she's still doing all the normal
stuff well at least we have more control
here if we have to she's a barn baby we
put him in the barn yeah is it too much
to hope that maybe this is a girl
oh it is
I don't know if you're looking for
honesty or just a wishful thinking I'm
telling you what man raw is just he's
been a thousand our bull rawha has given
us seven calves already here which is
great but the dude is like a male baby
Factory they have all been bulls and Jan
is really hoping it's a girl that's all
right I just want a healthy baby yeah I
do too it would be great to have another
lady in the herd
uh I guess we just keep watching her she
looks great I'm thinking just a week or
two at the most yep I'd say a couple
weeks
you're excited super excited you're
pumped draft baby coming but there's
also that feeling like of nervousness
she's moving more than what I typically
saw but you know that could be weather
too it's cooled down a little bit and
unless I see feet hanging out I really I
don't get much excited and that can
happen fast man it does it's just it's
gonna happen when it happens Lulu is so
special this baby is just going to speak
to my heart when it's born and I can't
wait to see it fingers and toes crossed
yeah no kidding thanks you guys yep
thanks guys
foreign
[Music]
I know usually everybody's getting
weighed just you today Fiona is our 13
year old orbital sheep and she is one of
our oldest animals hey pretty girl you
can tell our two females apart because
Fiona's got these buck teeth that hang
out and it always looks like she's got
this big huge smile on her face we're
gonna get a weight on Fiona she's gonna
have a medical procedure done on
Thursday she has a mass in her job and
we think it has something to do with her
teeth the way to help the Vets know how
much anesthetic and stuff that they need
to give her so they can give her the
proper amount come on scale go to scale
come on go to scale it's all right my
favorite animal with the zero the goats
and sheep they wiggle into your heart
real quickly not only have I birthed or
raised every goat or sheep that is down
there I have a personal connection with
them they're like my kids I'm pretty in
tune with how these guys are normally
and if they're acting off at all I can
usually sense it Teddy up at the vet
hospital calls me the goat Whisperer she
goes DD just knows
here we go good girl good job all the
way all the way two more feet one more
foot is there it is she's on
896. good job lady
I just want to feel that mass right now
the abscess on the side of her face is
about a quarter size and it's a round
hard ball about the same size doesn't
feel like we're getting ready to rupture
through
it's okay good job I'm gonna get that
taken care of for you
good girl see you later
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so I go down to draft to check on Lulu
like I always do and there's already
feet sticking out
so now it's go time
Lulu is just about to give birth and we
are so excited about this baby legs and
head were out for quite some time
without much progress so we got a little
bit worried because we want them to give
birth within that two hour period we
hadn't seen any movement either so we're
all kind of worried because sometimes
once the head's out you can start to see
a little bit of movement and just as we
were starting to gear up to be even more
worried she gave a push and the baby
came out
[Music]
foreign
that is awesome
seeing this baby for the first time is
incredible it's almost making me cry and
I am in love already
Lulu's calf is on the ground it looks
like it's alive we've seen movement but
now there's so many Milestones when
there's a major birth the birth itself
okay we can check that one off oh that
is awesome Mom's okay we can check that
one off good Mama
but now the next big milestone is for
the baby to stand up and we need the
baby to stand up within an hour or two
we're really on pins and needles trying
to figure out what gender this baby is
Braha has given us seven out of seven
boys so we kind of default to he with
this baby he's dark huh yeah like his
dad
oh wow wow
oh my goodness he's like maybe
[Music]
when it finally gets uh it's a huge
relief it's just one of those big
markers that we need to check off and
it's kind of funny because it wobbles
around like it's drum I mean literally
looks like some dude someone home from a
bar holy cow
yeah that's good no following yet so oh
we really want to see this baby up and
nursing in the first couple of hours
that first nursing provides the
antibodies that are going to keep this
baby safe from disease oh he's getting
in the right spot isn't he he's like
trying oh and he's in the right area he
is he's got his head right where it
needs to be
well it's right there
look at that
yeah he's stationary yeah I think he's
got it yep I think he's got it
nice
so the baby just nursed and we could
tell it was latched and I could actually
see swallowing I could see the baby was
getting something and swallowing this is
such a relief he's going back
yeah
yeah we're all smiling under our masks
[Laughter]
to be able to see her have a nice
healthy calf this is a real big moment
for us I've been here for almost 20
years now and you only see a handful of
draft kids in your time if you're lucky
and I consider myself very lucky
it's supposed to start raining like
three-ish is that what it said I'd hate
for it to get wet but I hate to move it
too soon we did check the weather and it
looks like it might start to rain this
afternoon and might get a little bit
cold we're going to reconvene about 2 30
and kind of check the weather again and
figure out if we have to do something to
get them in the barn
once we make that decision to come in in
the barn then we'll just kind of need to
have all hands on deck oh my gosh today
was such a great day this baby looks
really healthy but we always in the back
of our minds know that the first 24 to
48 hours of any baby's life human or
otherwise are so important but I
couldn't be happier I mean what a great
day what a great day
foreign
[Music]
don't sheep out on me oh my god oh wow
you guys want this
Fiona's gonna come up to the hospital
for a dental she definitely has
abscesses on at least two or three of
her teeth that need to come out the hope
is that after these teeth are gone
she'll have a lot of relief she won't be
as painful and she'll be able to eat
more comfortably all right there Mama
you're okay sweet girl I know there you
go
over the last couple months of caring
for few and I've gotten to know her a
little bit and I think to some degree
maybe earn some of her trust so it's
been a rewarding experience taking care
of Fiona I love her little front
teethers I don't know Katie she's
looking a little sheepish
no Jessica I'm not reinforcing this
thing
it can be oh
and if you can't get them all out in one
piece it can sometimes lead to more
issues so we're going to have our
specialist Dr Cairo come out she's got
the experience with a lot of different
animal teeth getting them out safely and
efficiently
this is Fiona she's got the micro
abscesses yeah and then she's got an
actual mandibular swell okay let me pull
it up again just so I can do it quickly
looking at the x-rays there are some
pretty significant abscesses there's the
one problem child that's causing that
swelling on her right lower jaw that one
for sure needs to come out but then
there's two others that could be
potentially causing problems in the
future
all right well let's get a look in there
we never know with the dental some of
them you get in there and the tooth pops
right out you're done but some we've had
go up and it's been hours you just never
know now we're getting loose
Dr Cairo starts in on the first tooth
it's kind of loose but she uses all of
her tools to get it really really loose
and then that one actually comes out
pretty quickly that's really nasty
it's her like signature thing her
so one tooth down two more to go
I don't know it's coming
and I've been wrong so many times that I
thought were gonna be just terrible and
they've come out easy I've had ones that
I got cocky about and then four hours
later I was still trying to get it out
while the first tooth came out pretty
easily the second tooth is not following
suit and is being very difficult to
remove wrong shape to come out of a hole
hooked Peg round hole someone tell me
when five minutes has passed and then
we're gonna make a decision um okay I
can do that even though Dr Cairo can get
a lot of Mobility it's almost in some
ways kind of fused with the bone and
it's just not coming out as easily all
right
now and ever yeah unfortunately we're
gonna have to just cut Chase now because
the roots are bigger than the ground I
mean I have surgical length Burrs at
school
about three hours into the process we
decide that we're going to call it for
the day and that we're actually going to
take Fiona down to Ohio State on Tuesday
for surgery because Dr Cairo has all of
her specialty tools down there that
she's going to need to remove this tooth
I think we should get back here as soon
as possible though okay because it's
Gonna Hurt it's a loose tooth yeah
Sometimes the best choice is to take a
step back we're sending Fiona back down
to the barn with antibiotics and pain
meds but we're going to make sure we get
her to Dr Cairo at OSU early next week
hi girlfriend how you doing huh she was
a rock starter in the whole procedure so
we're just gonna watch and wait keep her
on some pain medicine to keep her
comfortable until then and then just go
down to Ohio State on Tuesday hey
girlfriend she's still got some buck
teeth that hang out yeah you still got
your signature look I don't want to get
rid of the signature look nobody will
know how to find her
[Music]
firefly firefly come here
come on let's go
okay good girl
we've rechecked the weather and it's
going to get down to 55 tonight we're
supposed to have some rain and that is
dangerous weather for a neonatal calf so
this is not Lulu's first baby she gave
birth to a calf two years ago
we lost that baby during a cold snap now
we're going through the same thing again
it feels like deja vu so guys I just
want to ask one quick question before we
get into the plan there's risk in
whatever we do right so I just want to
make sure at the risk of leaving this
baby out is greater than the risk of
bringing it in if it's a little bit of
rain and in the 70s that's one thing but
rain followed by a drop in temp yeah
that's
concerning what we really need to focus
on right now is getting Lulu and this
kid in the barn we've got bad weather
rolling in and when you have a brand new
kid that literally it's his first day on
the planet they can be a lot more
susceptible to the colder temperatures
so it's just really important that we
get Lulu and this calf inside where we
can keep them in and they aren't exposed
of these elements it's about to go in I
think yeah once she goes in the barn
with the kid then we can shut the door
behind them and then just go okay we're
going to kind of use our two trucks to
kind of gently as easy as we can
maneuver her down towards the barn there
are so many ways that this could maybe
not work but we're in a position where
we're kind of damned if we do and damned
if we don't because there's a risk of
leaving her out and there's a risk of
trying to get her in which makes me
really nervous come on good looking
nice and slow Louie I may have you open
your door okay yeah you just tell me
when and how much what we need as we're
pushing her was a visual barrier so with
some animals all you do is put your arms
out with these guys what we did to make
the trucks look bigger is just open the
doors and that visual barrier is enough
for Lulu to say oh I can't go that way
and she'll turn around don't get in that
corner you do not want to get in that
corner
there we go good girl that'll work keep
doing that Lulu she knows that yard she
knows what a fence is she knows what all
this stuff is this calf doesn't so we're
trying to move her but at the same time
we got to pay attention to what he's
doing because if he crashes into a fence
we could end up with broken bones so if
it worse a broken neck I'm gonna let her
get off the fence hope she's going for
that hole Yeah I do too baby's following
really well yeah it is he's sticking
with her real good with a process of
trucks inching along the fence and not
allowing her to Circle back it is an
incredible amount of Precision driving
I'm hoping she's going to flip that
switch and just go and we're in because
the kids huffing and puffing and
nostrils flaring and she's huffing and
puffing the last thing we need is for
either Lulu or especially the baby to
get really worked up or start to run and
stumble and fall I am a warrior and I'm
going to worry through this whole
process she's real close though like if
she goes I know then we're good at this
point I'm not sure if there's babies
going make it in the barn tonight and
that could be a very bad situation we
never pushed one in like this oh come on
you're right there come on sweetie just
go in you know you want to
come on sweetheart with the temperature
going down the baby being less than 24
hours old it's important for us to try
and get them in the barn
let's just keep her here keep her still
looks like she wants to go inside she's
looking at it she's definitely looking
at it yeah
there you go good looking good girl just
go you got 10 more feet come on there
she goes good girl nice freaking job bud
good job guys
I had a baby Lulu
okay Court we've got him in the yard
Lulu we're here you just go straight in
there and you go baby
good girl we finally get her walked in
there and the big thing is is this kid
if he doesn't follow and she goes deeper
in that barn and he gets spooked and
Pops back out we're in a lot of trouble
get up there kid come on yeah get in
there get in there get in there get in
there
okay cool yeah that wasn't stressful at
all
stuff like that is what you live for but
you also like oh there's so much on the
line the culmination from her being into
labor and all the steps that we'd
accomplished to recognizing there was
bad weather coming of all things in
August and getting them into the sand
stall was a huge relief so what's the
plan for tomorrow oh God I don't know
tomorrow we really hope to do a neonatal
exam if we can find a safe way to do it
if we can get Lulu safely away from the
calf and get our hands on it then we're
going to really learn what gender this
baby is and you know Raja has given us
seven out of seven boys and I kind of
thought maybe there's a chance it could
be a girl and a Kurt kind of thought
maybe it was and I think part of that's
wishful thinking but we're not going to
know for sure until we get the neonatal
exam done
foreign
[Music]
wait
wait
good jackpot
I don't know that's how you train an
alligator that's a high train alligator
Korea
I'm here cool
evil lap yes today we're going to be
doing x-rays on two shingle back skinks
one cold Spike and one called Vegemite
one of the things that we've been
worried about spike is why she is unable
to maintain weight
look at this guy like how he's chunky
and his tail looks like
all right Daddy-o to the X-ray we really
want to try and compare how big the
stomach is in the so-called normal skink
versus Spike okay ready six feet back
guys
so let's do the little one real quick
come on Hi friend
spike is our concern because we see the
weight Decline and so we just want to be
able to compare these two and understand
what's going on internally she's just
adorable and cute and just oh I'm
amazing she's an amazing animal
it's where that's totally different
Korea well the stomach shouldn't be all
I think the stomach is flattened down
here because I think the lungs are
potentially pressing everything flat
yeah yeah we're confident that big daddy
stomach is completely normal and Spike's
stomach which was very low and very
small and very back in the body is
actually really abnormal it's very
apparent that Spike's stomach is a lot
smaller and being pushed down into an
abnormal location because of the lungs
so what this means for her is it
probably is playing a significant role
in her ability to take in enough food
unfortunately it's not something that
we're going to be able to fix because
her lungs have been expanded that much
for so long but it helps us understand a
little bit more about how she is able to
take in food and maintain weight
so I think we can conclude yes it's
abnormal yes it may be a part of why she
can't eat enough right based off her
stomach and the x-rays do you feel like
she still has the capacity to eat a
normal amount I mean we put 12 mils so
if you imagine like that much food it's
still quite a lot of food that she could
try and RAM in there okay
but she might get that feeling of
fullness faster true right because it's
compressing from the outside yeah like
how lungs are pushing it down yeah
ultimately it is good news that we did
this barium series just knowing the
shape and the size and the location of
her stomach definitely is one piece of
the puzzle but we're definitely not
going to be able to solve this mystery
overnight we know that she's gonna need
really high calorie food items so we
know her stomach is small so whatever
she takes in has to be very calorie
dense to get the same amount of calories
as eating a large amount of food like
the other guy we develop relationships
with these animals and some of them
become our favorites and so anytime that
we're dealing with a health concern it
makes us a little bit nervous on what
the outcome is today though is something
that we know that we're on that right
path we're pushing Spike towards greater
success and a longer life here at the
Columbus Zoo
cheetah vet giraffe vet and now reptiles
it I prefer
expert okay sorry my fault
[Applause]
[Music]
are you all right if we bring candle out
yeah I think that's great you think
they're ready to play you want to play I
think David well Dave needs to get some
energy out
Adrian and Dave in my opinion are the
two most valuable cheetahs in the world
because they were the first in vitro
fertilized transferred babies and we're
always trying to find ways how can we
save a species and cheetahs are in so
much trouble you're talking 7 500
cheetahs left in the wild
we have an incredible cheetah companion
dog programming and we know that
cheetahs are skittish by nature but if I
raise them with a dog they just kind of
grow up together and they think they're
one of a kind cheetahs are going to take
their cues from their siblings and if
they think the puppy is their sibling
and the puppy has all the confidence in
the world then they're not afraid you
ready to see your puppy camel's gonna
come play with you your brother for the
first time I think with this
introduction we really have to monitor
what they do and I don't want a good
situation to turn bad
Campbell
we've raised our cheetahs with dogs for
almost 10 years and now we have Campbell
the double doodle today I really want
them just to run around play Chase each
other I don't want to see them yelling
and barking and growling and swatting at
each other
Campbell
all right
oh
what are you doing pop you're so
handsome all right Dave go play with
your pup so Campbell he is just two days
older than Adrian and Dave he's very
energetic very outgoing just wants to
play all the time get them
you sweet boy
don't eat them I really look for certain
characteristics when I look for a dog
and you don't want something that's so
hyper that it's gonna drive the Cheetahs
crazy but yet you don't want something
so shy that it's not going to interact
or it's going to be afraid of everything
this is so good for them I think they're
going to be best friends I hope so
that's the goal BFFs forever oh okay
Dave loved him
they're like two Rowdy little boys get
them
get him Campbell get the kitty
this has been truly one of my greatest
career accomplishments to have been a
part of Dave and Adrian those cheetahs
represent what could happen in the wild
that because of those two we could save
this species
you know people always ask us what's
harder to raise the cheetahs or the
puppy it's the puppy it's by far the
puppy
let's get some toys
okay you want to grab a lure ball yeah I
asked Susie to get a lure ball so we can
get them playing with that and then get
them running here hopefully soon look
what I have
Campbell that's what we use up at our
cheetah run the Cheetahs will chase that
lure ball around the course and they've
been around it since they were just a
couple weeks old so it is a super
valuable toy for them I think we need to
get them up to run we need to get them
up to the water yep
here at the Columbus zoo we do three
cheetah runs a day it's very good for
the Cheetahs but you have to train them
to do it we need to get them running
yeah it's time
that was your own fault
[Music]
Fiona
what you doing Mama come here
okay
no
Fiona is one of our 13 year old sheep
oldest member of our flock we attempted
to extract the worst teeth that she was
experiencing we were able to get one out
but unfortunately the second was not
possible to be removed with the
equipment that our dentist had with her
at the time so we elected to bring her
later in the week to see Dr Cairo for
completion of that removal however today
things have changed
where you are Katie um put on the floor
this morning we put her in a crate put
her in the back of the van to take Fiona
down to Ohio State we noticed that
Fiona's side of the jaw where the
abscess was was really swollen up now
it's about a grapefruit in size this is
vastly different than
earlier
when I look at her her face is
completely swollen and this is new so
I'm really concerned that there's
something really serious going on we're
so close to getting her to Dr Cairo at
OSU and now this changes everything
so that are intubated grab a blood
sample get that rolling and then we'll
move to CT our priority right now is to
stabilize her give her supportive care
hopefully some drugs that are going to
start making her feel better and then
try and figure out what the heck is
going on because looking at her it
doesn't fit perfectly with any one thing
and we need to get some more information
to figure out what the underlying cause
is
her whole face is dramatically more
swollen than it was you think the whole
thing might be related to that
two-through area I don't know this looks
like an allergic reaction to me now so
this isn't ideal but we're gonna give
our steroids whatever's happening
we're gonna get some additional Imaging
to make sure there's nothing else we
need to be addressing
sweet Fiona
it's kind of a helpless feeling
especially when that's all you can do is
move and be comforting to them and when
you're looking around at all the vets
that you trust very much and they're
kind of at a loss too just it just you
know you just want answers
waking up wait wait wait wait what catch
the pee
that's good
immediately I can tell that this urine
isn't correct it's brown in color which
is usually related to there being blood
in the urine which to me is the worst
case scenario because this means she's
bleeding from her kidneys or from her
bladder directly and nothing that causes
that is good
foreign
[Music]
immediately I can tell that this urine
isn't correct it's brown in color which
is usually related to there being blood
in the urine
given that there's blood in her urine
it'd be nice let's give her some IV
antibiotics
my heart is breaking for but hopefully
we can figure it out
she's also a 13 year old sheep that's
not working in her favor at the moment
we're gonna give her the night with this
treatment we're going to recheck blood
first thing in the morning if things
aren't looking markedly better then
we're gonna not do surgery tomorrow
you just power through and your mind is
racing your heart's racing there's a lot
of things going on in your head
we need to be able to give these drugs a
chance to work and for her to rest and
allow her body to heal while they take
effect so Dede is going to take the
first watch during this kind of critical
period post procedure until we see where
we're at and then one of her team
members is going to come relieve her all
right Dede I'm going to close you in
so to go to sleep sweetheart
[Music]
about three hours and 45 minutes into my
shift I kind of looked over and her
respiration rate kind of looked odd they
were slowing down quite a bit so I
immediately got on my radio and get Dr
Seeley back to the back and bring more
supportive care okay
we came back and DD's already started
CPR okay
by the time they got from the front of
the hospital to the back of the hospital
she had stopped breathing and not very
long after she had passed
in those moments it's
you're not just a bat right like we're a
team
I take it very seriously that my role is
to be as honest with team members as I
can be and to also let them know when
it's okay to let go because
DD loves this animal she's gonna fight
as long as she can as hard as she can
and that wasn't the best choice for
Fiona
ire
yeah it's all
you uh put your life into these guys or
like your family and uh
it's a real heart especially when you're
sitting there and you're like
everything's gonna be okay everything's
gonna be okay and then the next minute
it's not I'm glad that it was Dede that
was there with her because Stevie has
helped raise her she gives so much love
and kindness to these animals that at
least her last moments were spent with
someone who really cared about her Fiona
lived a fantastic life but I know that
we gave everything we could to her to
try and get her back to being healthy
and that just wasn't going to be the
outcome today
these animals are part of our family and
offense
it's hard they don't live long none of
our animals live past the age of 18 so
over your career you're going to lose
quite a few of them
and it's just hard we have to take pride
in the fact that at 13 years old this
animal lives past its life expectancy it
was living a good life it'll always
bring a smile to my face when I think
about her I'll remember and think happy
thoughts you got to live with the happy
moments because you just do or you can't
go on
it's okay I know something I'm Gonna Be
With You
[Music]
Adam you just want to call us when you
want us to come in yeah we want to get
in there and listen to its heart we want
to check its mouth to make sure it
doesn't have a cleft palate so no
congenital abnormalities it really did
get pretty cold last night and we made
the right call I'm really glad we got
Lulu and the baby in this looks like a
really strong healthy calf it seems to
be a champ and we're going to do
everything we can to keep this calf
healthy including a neonatal exam and
I'm really anxious to see what the
gender is who doesn't want to know
gender and secretly I'm hoping for a
little girl but I'll take a healthy boy
all right ready to do it yeah raise
whatever Bae Adam's coming be the lead
on this one he's the draft guy Cody and
I will back him up this is going to try
to be like a NASCAR pit stop we're going
to try to get in there get a hold of
this thing get it against the wall vets
come in do their thing and everybody out
try to leave Lulu separated the least
amount of time possible
hey pretty girl good girl
I like it
[Music]
you got her homeboy yep
nice good deal
201 301 we've got her separated and
we're gonna go ahead and grab the kit
ten four
okay Duke I think we'll just walk into a
corner
here
okay we're good
oh he's strong yeah yeah he is my phone
am I holding him good you it looks great
looks great a couple injections Dr
Priscilla goes in and was able to
determine there's no clef she listens to
the heart she looks in the eyes
everything is going really well it's a
fine oiled machine I'm really proud of
the team lift his tail Adam huh
once we know that the baby's healthy the
next step is trying to determine the
gender what is it Adam huh
here go right there
[Laughter]
dude that looks great looks great what
is it Adam lift his tail Adam huh once
we know that the baby's healthy the next
step is trying to determine the gender
he looks like a one holder to me about
it
can you guys double check back here no
yeah dang it should be a boy
there's a few things in life to bet on
but right consistent
we double check the sex twice because
some people didn't believe it was going
to be but it was we're done nice thanks
guys
we're done like that's it like we're
done the Vets nailed it
right back in there
[Music]
it's one of those things that seems
really simple and it looked really
simple but that stuff can go sideways so
fast
all right we done with draft stress for
a little bit yeah
[Music]
hey can you come up go ahead boy
hi Sean hello Priya I see your little
friends outside yeah so I just thought
it was a nice day and obviously getting
her outside just to get some natural
sunlight and I have blueberries too her
favorite we really obviously love spike
and we want to do the best for her the
main goal for her is to maintain her
weight maintain an appropriate quality
of life and make sure that she is
getting everything that she needs while
remaining as healthy as she can
she looks so cute right now look at her
she's been all over the place I have to
keep hunting her Downs are you serious
yeah she loves it outside yeah in terms
of all the things that we found we know
that her stomach is a little smaller
than the big one the normal one so I
think that's probably part of the reason
she can't seem to take in enough food
that's just a theory yeah
the next few steps are really just a lot
of convalescence a lot of care sunlight
offering her different types of food as
well as different presentations and I
really do believe that she will get
better eventually and that's the beauty
of working in this field in the
Zoological field it gives me the
opportunity to work with so many
different species and help so many
animals every single day doesn't mean to
say it doesn't get stressful with all of
those emergency calls that come in and
all of the strange things that we have
to scratch our heads about and go oh my
gosh I've never seen this or what's
going on but that's what makes our job
really challenging but that's also what
makes it really fun and what makes it
really worthwhile putting in all the
time and energy to help these animals
she's cruising out here she's a
wonderful little creature she really
lets us do a lot with her for her things
with reptiles definitely do turn around
quickly and in Spike's case we're still
working on her over a year so a lot of
patience
[Music]
today is a huge day for Dave and Adrian
it is time for them to learn to run in
the watering hole you ready to see some
cheetahs run for the first time well
we'll see exercising cheetahs is very
important we know if we don't
incorporate exercise at a very young age
that they'll end up with Metabolic Bone
Disease so it's very very important that
we run them it's very very important
that they get time to run around and
exercise and develop those bones and
muscles
but just because they're cheetahs and
they're the fastest land mammal doesn't
mean they know how to run
I figure Dave's probably going to be the
better of the two and Adrian she kind of
likes the shade nope here they come here
they come all right here he is oh oh
Dave's Running almost caught it Dave
acts like he knows what he's doing he
comes right out of the shoot he sees the
ball and he immediately goes after it
all right buddy
you did it
doesn't know what's going on Adrian on
the other hand it's kind of like she's
almost seemed a little nervous I thought
let's try it again because Adrian was so
close to being a part of the Run
we're gonna try again come on girl
good good
come on girl on the second run Adrian
gets it she's neck and neck with her
brother they're going after the lure
come on uh
she's like I'm done
they both did so good it made me so
proud of both of them
did really good you actually ran yes you
did you're a good girl
[Music]
that was awesome
[Music]
[Music]